This right here is a blue tang, the real-life Dory.
They only live on coral reefs in the south Pacific.
But before we get to her story, let's talk about Nemo, the clownfish.
When "Finding Nemo" came out, well okay, I'll let Karen tell you.
I'm Karen Burke Da Silva, I'm a marine biologist...
...and a conservation biologist here at Flinders University of South Australia.
So, what happened with "Finding Nemo"?
After the release of "Finding Nemo,"...
we found that there was quite a big increase...
...in the number of people that wanted a clownfish as a pet.
With the increase in demand, it did have an increase in captive breeding,...
...but it also meant that more fish were being taken from the wild.
Most collectors in Australia will use a very careful collecting measures.
In other parts of the world, in Southeast Asia,...
...they are using cyanide still to collect aquarium fish.
Hmmm, that's not good.
But there is hope.
Matt and his team are working hard to breed blue tangs successfully.
There's only one other tang species, the yellow tang,...
...that's ever been raised in captivity before.
And we're hoping that the blue tang will be the second.